foreign
years ago
the world fell to [__] a big old
apocalyptic dunk some bug took out all
the world's computers power grids down
the internet gone and not having easily
accessible porn freaked people the [__]
out
so cities put up walls to protect
themselves and threw the criminals out
into the chaos so they could fight over
what was left which was not much mostly
cars and guns
now insiders stay inside and Outsiders
stay outside but they are people who
drive between badasses
Legends humble [__] like me
delivering Precious Cargo from one
walled City to another
it's not an easy road because all these
[__] want what I got
and the guns come in
awesome tunes
Evelyn May I Have This Dance
[Music]
holy [__]
okay I got Barry so who's left Gary
Larry got it
friendly
don't you do it don't you even think
about it
I know
we're exit it's like a goddamn maze in
here
[Music]
I'm here then the exit is oh they have a
Foot Locker
baby
[Music]
it's all good
hey there
ID
he's a Milkman it must be our delivery
yeah they know me I'm here all the time
hey Doug hey John he's new a virgin oh I
got a big package for you all the way
from Paso Robles some vultures wanted it
real bad but not bad enough you know
what I mean hey that better be unleaded
93 in there 91 gives Evelyn the squirts
the trunk
a few to
deliver you're such a lamb where too
fresh battery to the Greensboro colony
in the usual shipment of medicine in new
San Francisco new San Fran it's been a
month already
[Music]
Abner Abner really I mean it's a nice
name you just don't meet too many Anyway
come here
how about you let me uh slip inside
outside take it easy relax
attaboy all right this has been a gas
I'll see your shiny faces in a month
till then Abner eat up
[Music]
the Milkman bring us this time
tonight we feast
see a milkman's job is never done
it's a big world out there
but at the end of the day all that
matters is me
Evelyn and the road
[Music]
thank you